Pues otro fracaso para la primera
ministra Elizabeth Aunque tomó a pocos
por sorpresa la única reunión entre la
unión intersindical y el gobierno desde
que se presentó la reforma de pensiones
no fue más que un diálogo de sordos
ambas partes confirmaron su
intransigencia la primera ministra
descartó por completo La retirada de la
polémica reforma de pensiones y
precisamente esa desestimación del texto
era la condición cinecuanón de la unión
sindical para avanzar con otros temas
intentó ella pasar página al ofrecer
negociar una ley de pleno empleo
propuesta por el presidente Emmanuel
macron algo que por supuesto los
sindicatos rechazaron de inmediato
dijeron que el gobierno sea radicalizado
y que la crisis social se está
convirtiendo en una crisis democrática
La Premier por su parte insiste en que
no podrá avanzar y no quiere avanzar sin
el acuerdo de las organizaciones
sociales francesas algo que será muy
difícil mientras no se da mientras no de
su brazo
a torcer a torcer por el momento una
nueva jornada de manifestaciones
anunciada para mañana continúan las
huelgas en todo el país 40% de
gasolineras por ejemplo aquí en la
región Parisina sin gasolina o sin
Diesel 20% de los educadores también en
huelga y veremos qué sucede mañana en
las calles de todo el país